[Music]
all right welcome everybody to the
endgame exclaim at the st. Louis chest
pump today my name is Vitaly namer and
I'm going to be you Grand Master
resident first of all I would like to
show you a little quick my my new
updated website actually got some new
features over here there's the reviews
on the left so if you will have time at
any point like me a small review also
you can send me a quick message over
here I don't promise to respond
immediately but I will do my best and
then you have this nice guy pop out over
here on the left side which which asks
you to give a like for Facebook and if
you click on it it's actually going to
be usually it's going to be opening up
the Facebook page I just wanted to show
you quick and the Facebook page is
called powerful chest so facebook.com
slash powerful chest and you can see
different reviews and news and so on I
also published a few articles lately
about chats and comics also how to dress
up like a grandmaster you can yes and
not not always but yes make sure that
you follow the rules of the shorts but
yeah you basically want to be
comfortable wear something comfortable
to beat you opponents okay alrighty so
that's pretty much about me about my
website about my Facebook page so now we
can go in and dive into chess and today
we are going to discuss some end games
and today we're going to see some
mighty night mighty night and games
which is which are going to give you
some nightmares nightmares okay
so let's look at our first position here
it looks like we usually know that end
games with a king and a knight on our
side I'll actually draw but in this
current position black actually has two
points for the night and they'd look
pretty dangerous I mean if I bring this
pawn to g3 g2 I'm even going to Queen
and win the game so it is why to move
you are going to be playing white you
might need to save the game if you
succeed in in winning the game then you
even get that point so good luck and
take your best shot
it's white to move so Knight of 6 if g5
king h1
and if h2 9f2 very good if you are
playing as wide is actually pretty easy
to win with nine of six g5 Knight to g4
check King to each one and now King to
f1 which puts black into zoos Wong he
has to play h2 and now the night is
jumping to f2 and creates a checkmate
very good now let's try to solve the
same position but it is going to be
black to move now as black I would
probably play my first move would be
king - h1 so think about this one it is
my base might be still winning
so give you a best shot Knight f6 the
first move okay and if I play h2
g5
g4
chiefly check
very good all right let's see this
variation night of six so same idea
night of 6 if g 5 then 94 h 2 9 e 3g 4 &
9 f 1 or night of 5 GT and checkmate all
right very good this is the first
variation what about after Knight f6 I
can actually play King 2 h 2 when I try
to make your life more difficult
nothing personal just my job
if Knight G [ __ ] H 1 King G 1
yeah Unitas on g4 right the King can
take the pawn but then my Kings on in
King f1 that citizen quick in G clicking
G 1 freedom do not let the King out of
his prison
94 king h1
engage to King h1 now King h2
the matron on your cure whatever the age
porn is moving right so we have to put
him in a zoos one the only way to put
him in zoos one the H pawn we also have
to put this pawn on g6
on into the tubes one night
efore g4 king h1 okay g5g for h2
wait that's it I have no moves now you
King and as an f-1 the point is not on
it didn't take okay let's look at this
so King g94 is the first move that's
correct
King h1 and then what you say Keinath
one is also correct very good so now I
can't play h2 because of the mate so g5
93 I guess you know breaking h2
alright and here's the checkmate very
good there's another solution after
after g5 what can also play King F 2 h2
and now Knight e3 so the same same idea
pretty much and now forcing me to play
g4 and now neither fun ok so very nice
so even in such end games which we
usually are not so common with the night
versus pawns you can still win
now here's another another a theoretical
position which is good to know this case
you are actually going to be white and
you're going to have a knight and upon
just against the king but it is going to
be excuse me black to move so what do
you guys thing if it's a black to move
there's white win here so there is
actually a way for black to make it drop
but you have to make the correct move
king f7 and if 97
okay 98
90 g7
96 yeah so that's that's a pretty easy
one right so that so the question is
where should we put our our piece all
night do we put it on f7 on f7 or f8 so
the one that makes a draw is King to f7
because now once the night K it comes
he's gonna check the King
oops that's my night I was the night
became a ghost check yeah and now King
f7 and apparently there is no winner on
the other hand if the King would go to
f8 this would be winning for White was
probably just 96 for example and the
knight is taking this square from the
king
the King has to take and
all right so there is another very
famous position let's see if you get if
you guys will know about this one now in
this case I'm gonna give you night two
pawns against just one pawn now this
position it is white to move so why to
move and obviously white is trying to
draw so think about this one how can we
draw so let's start with the first most
of the everybody think about the first
move because there is only one drawing
move here for white okay so think about
the first mover then we going to
continue later
okay that's possible
so I get a difference we have to find a
difference between King b6c 6 and d6
obviously those are the only options we
have because otherwise the knight would
move and there's no way that the King
can capture the pawn so the question is
what was the difference between those
three moves
two of them are losing one of them is
drawing yeah doesn't doesn't look like
yes apparently this is actually a drum
well otherwise I want to put it but yes
why it is drawing this okay so let's say
I saw a hilt some people said king c6
right
some people said King d6 anyone [ __ ]
b6
no and that's correct key so King b6 who
probably very easily lose because the
night will come and defend the pawn from
efore right the king can get to the
neither especially our King comes very
very fast to defend the night and this
position is just completely lost now for
the same reasons king d6 is also losing
because that's correct Knight to a4 and
the King has to go to d5 King g7 King c4
King
he has to go to b5
then the king is supporting the pawn so
this is lost
so therefore the correct mode is came to
c6 you guys alright ok so let's see
what's the difference well if Knight a 4
then King be 5 I'm gonna win the pond so
the best move for black is to play
Knight to e4 now white is obviously
playing King to d5 the only move so we
have to continue attacking both the pawn
and the knight on e4 now if black and
gives away the night then white has
enough time to take capture of the night
capture this pawn and come back for the
pawn so for example and he just slide on
right in time he can thinking of - Oh
king of 1 so this is a drop ok so let's
say we're playing black and we would
like to keep all night but now the night
starch is a hunt for the h2 pawn so
let's say the night goes to g5 now a we
have to take the pawn otherwise we have
no chance of fighting all those pieces
and Knight to f3 so what to do now yeah
so if Kim d5 what happens is so if i
take the pawn h21 who your next move
yeah yeah that's correct okay so the
first tip for today is that when the
King is fighting against a knight you
want to put the King just diagonally
over the over in front of there it's
kind of the other diagonal opposition
that we have because yeah because from
here the King is going to control those
both squirrel's now the night is going
to go to different other way but there
just makes much more sense to bring the
King as close as possible king c4 would
just lose two key knight eh - and just
Knight to g4 now even well in this case
the the night the king is not even close
to get into the night so get to the pawn
so King to d5 is the correct move the
knight takes the pawn and King to e4
that's correct now okay so how should
black play again his king is very very
far so the King does not meddle so much
so let's say the night is going to g4
now it actually looks like this position
is completely lost for white right but
the best way for Y to continue would be
but the only move King f2e right because
black is threatening to
aah - so the only way to stop the pond
is king to f3 mm-hmm so now let's say
black sets up a trap and he plays King
to g7 so yes so the only move for white
again in the chaotic deny because the
pawn is going to be pushed forward so
King to g3 now this move already forces
black to push his pawn and if the for
example if the knight would be able
somehow to jump to g5 those positions
are one for black so in those kind of
end games if the pawn reaches the second
rank this is actually going to end up in
a draw so let's let's see an example
so King g6 King h1 yeah so there is not
nothing much you can do because the
knife has to stay here to defend the
pawn once you move then I take the pawn
and they really did the black King
doesn't have any any way to approach the
pawn
yeah so the technique is if you have a
pond if you have a pawn up now this way
they didn't work but if you have a pawn
up if you could jump with the night for
example to g5 the best way to defend
upon this form obviously from behind
because the night the King cannot get to
him but if the night would be on g5 and
you would leave the pawn on h3 this
would be winning because the king can
come in and there is no stalemate once
you move the king so imagine that the
knight will be on g5 so once you bring
your king all of the to g3 then my king
will be on h1 you going to bring your
knight to f1 which is going to take the
h1 square there to have to check and
then it you push h2 h1 okay now similar
similar to this position even if white
has a pawn in addition to this so for
example see if I can try to
for example if in this position black
would try to just bring his king very
fast so King g7 King takes e5 King f6
King D 491 King here 593 he F talking a
for Kim Ji Won and basically it's
impossible for black to drive the white
king from from the corner
okay any any questions about this this
line alright so we had we had a warm-up
so now we are going to go to the
advanced level this was a warm-up okay
now we are going to be fighting for a
draw but once we have the night so let's
see what is the strategy when we have a
night very very far and I know that we
all have this fear this nightmare that
we have a pawn we we got this endgame
with a knight and we somehow need to
stop his pawn so right now it's an hh6
points of a dangerous point so I put it
the farthest one so in this position it
is white to move so think about how what
is the way for for--why to draw this not
not so easy this one is a tough one so
make sure you calculate ill then
okay so some hints so basically what we
are striving to achieve is that if the
knight is able to touch any one of those
squares the pawn is going to to be
moving to there's going to be a draw
except the h1 because if you put the net
on h1 my king is going to come to g2 and
capture the night so somehow before it
reaches one of those squares the knight
has to touch one of those squares now
how do we do it
that's a good question that's the
question for you guys following for in
the variation yeah so the correct move
in this position is Knight to be four
now before I do that let's see that see
what the other well 91 doesn't make a
lot of sense right because the knight
cannot move cannot jump exactly
if night night city looks the most
logical move but unfortunately after h5
and check on on d5 we already discussed
that that the king has to move
diagonally to the night that's when he
is capturing and protecting those to
keep squares f4 and III and now maybe
the knight doesn't have is too slow
okay
so the correct move is night to be 4-h
five and knight c6 okay so the variation
is we just looked at was if if black
plays h4 then now night is going to be
five now king fo does not work because
of 96 and that's it we sacrifice the
night and pretty much any other move
with kingi for h3 then the night
succeeds in touching this square the h2
square
well so here I assume yeah so actually
it's actually it's a good point so what
is the best move helpful black to do
very good yes
kingi for this is the main line so why
to move nigh d8h for king of five h2e
yeah so this position a blacks last fall
was keen to e4 it's white to move and
white is trying to make a drop not so
easy you can get to have to write but
you get to h1
I wanna show this variation really quick
if we were trying to play King 98 right
here was a good idea because if I push
h3 then you have this fork but I played
King of five here here then you got to
have two but a member
h1 is not good enough because now the
King comes here and gain G 2 so we have
to to use a different square
so that's let's make a bet
all right we need to make a move let's
say we have a time pressure I mean we
can't calculate till the end probably
probably even I wouldn't be able to
calculate so what will be your bet there
is night obviously the King move does
not help us right it's too slow
so if 97 there is 98 before a 5 and B 8
right but he already going is going to
h4 it's too fast
98 okay okay so let's look at those so
if 97 that's not in time right here
let's try to begin the night the king is
again blocking the night of the way and
that's it so 97 doesn't work night b8 is
completely out of the way it's too much
98 I assume that he's going to come to
his 6 right we cannot push h3 but here I
think that that was our first try but
now he like King f5 check and I came to
g4
and probably only tries 92 but that's it
he's gonna push h2 next mode right can I
prevent H 2 h 2 so let's try this night
f 7 then King F 4 I talk because I want
to control a 5 and G 5 yeah that's
probably H 6 is in D 6 sorry for trying
all the squares so good try
now night before is where we came from
so night before we don't really want to
go to T 5 and D 3 so night before does
not work hence all its option Knight a5
very difficult position but the key but
the key idea is that the night is going
to get this key square on c4 ok so let's
see let's see what is the night going
form from c4 now obviously if black
pushes the pawn to h3 that's immediately
a draw right and night of fun that's it
we touched the h2 square that's all what
we need
so HT does not work the best move for
black is King to f3 any other move I
would go to D to f1 key if King D 3 I
assume it's checking Knight g4 so came
to f3 is the best chance that black has
right now that is that now if he plays
Knight d2 thinking to g2
actually I'm so if 92
kingi - is this is a mistake because the
years 94 so King Ito has to be played
and if 94 then h3 looks like we got a
pawn but again we're only touching the
h1 square so here I can play King f2 and
the next move kimchi - good question so
yeah it's not so easy to see but this
then I can go back with a Knight to c4
right either f1 or g4 ok so King f3 so
we said 92 is not working because Keeney
- so that leaves us with only option
King to Knight to e5 check that's
correct so the King has to go diagonally
as we said to the knight King to GT you
cannot go to f4 because of 96
all right so how to draw here this
position there is this dragons drawing
and there is losing so 93
and
so 94 h3 in 92 but then I have came to
g2 okay well this work doing something
right here on 94 right h3 and yeah the
drawing move is 93 and so the 90s trying
to come to g4 or f1 to control the h2
square if Knight to d2 looks similar but
now he's not coming to g4 he's only
attacking this square and after kingi to
block is ringing so I put a difficult
endgame yes especially especially the
first move as well
Knight to before was very difficult to
see then 96 yeah baby okay so now you
guys are warmed up for the next one in
this case you were fighting against one
point let's see if you can make a draw
versus two points but in this case at
least I'm going to give you the king
into the game I'm gonna ease your pain
okay so in this position a black is
going down here's two points you're
playing white and it's a white to move
yes miracles do happen
babe Oh black is going down this way Kim
be taking a six
night no night if six I'm just gonna
take the night yes so can be thinking
it's a scheme before king of five
if you take the pawn in h5 and you're
out of the square
so the idea here is that first of all
this b5 pawn is not a threat but we need
to get the night out from h7 to fight
the h6 pawn now right now we cannot move
the knight so we have to move the King
but the biggest question is where to
move the King a 3 B 3 B 2 or B 1 so we
have to figure out what it was different
very good yeah so King b2 and king b1 do
not work I just gonna show it a little
quick because now I'm just gonna take
the knight at age 5 again we are out of
the square so that leaves us with only
two options b3 + a3 tempo with the check
would be 4 okay interesting idea
so let's try this so as we said King b3
King e6 right Adam I cannot push the
poem because the knife is gonna get out
so King e6 so the idea is that now we
need to get out the night all night okay
but we have to calculate the route of
the night where is it going going going
to go so for example night of fate king
of 5 then what Knight d7 right the only
the only move H 5 then what other night
is going
see five but now I have h4 and if you
count to d3 you are not in time
this position is losing for white so
so the first move has to be king a three
let's see let's see what's the idea
King e6 bingo check king of 597 so the
King stays you have to fight the pawn
but the biggest difference is that after
95 the night is coming to be three okay
so we get to the same position but in
this case the night is going to be three
so let's see what what is the difference
so night be three and now if h-street so
how do we draw here maybe two so h2 and
queen
yeah yeah well you can see that that's
correct tonight - D - that's the whole
idea
now if I don't play h2 then I get to f1
and I touch the square and that's enough
for a draw and if H 2 then this is the
whole point
Knight 2 F 1 H 1 and I get the Queen
I can I can also probably make a nice
but I can check a king before yes just
for the beauty so the whole puzzle it
was a difficult puzzle but the idea was
to figure out that we have to bring the
knight out and to see you the route how
do we bring them so King b3 this is why
King bee tree is losing because we have
to keep this square for the knight
well King b2 would probably lose because
King of 7 and now the his King is coming
to take the knight so we are not in well
the new king is closed a good question
if King a3
then yeah we are getting into the square
and v3 alright hopefully you guys you
won't have any nightmares today but I
have some puzzles for you if you guys
want to take some thank you for coming
today
and I hope to see you for the rest of
the classes this week
[Music]
you
[Music]